[Music]
fertilizer prices have hit record highs
driven by supply shortages caused by the
ukraine russia war along with a host of
pre-existing factors
it's a challenge for all of us
agriculture right now for farmers who
are just walking in to buy fertilizer
today
they're twice as expensive as they would
have been last august close to three
times as costly as they would have been
in early 2021. fertilizer is typically
among farmers biggest expenses each year
and the rising costs are creating
cascading impacts for farmer incomes
crop yields and food prices
broadly speaking that is a big concern
for food production and if other parts
of the world can't get their fertilizer
in then it becomes what some ceos have
warned as a global food crisis so what's
driving these surging fertilizer prices
and what does that mean for farmers and
your grocery bills
like many products and services during
the pandemic fertilizer prices have been
impacted by global supply chain
challenges there's a lot of elements
that go into manufacturing fertilizer
and how it's produced it requires
different ingredients and natural gas
from all different parts of the world if
one of those things is disrupted it
throws off the entire supply chain for
how fertilizer is produced
there are several key factors behind the
global fertilizer supply crunch driving
high prices first various trade
restrictions in 2021 led to a steep
drop-off in fertilizer exports in
december the u.s and european union
imposed sanctions on belarus this halted
exports of potash a key ingredient in
mineral fertilizers belarus is the
world's third largest potash provider
meanwhile trade restrictions from china
turkey egypt and russia led to reduced
fertilizer exports in the second half of
2021.
china banned phosphate exports in 2021
when a country like china
cuts off its exports that
sends prices all over the world up
in february economic fallout from
russia's invasion of ukraine further
compounded the strain on fertilizer
production
russia is the world's largest fertilizer
exporter providing around 15 percent of
the world's nitrogen-based fertilizers
and 17 of the global potash supply the
west's financial sanctions against
moscow combined with transportation
challenges linked to the war led to a
sharp decline in russian exports if you
are going to export out of russia
the insurance on vessels is very
expensive that keeps people from getting
fertilizers out
at the same time rising natural gas
prices have prompted some european
factories to scale back fertilizer
production
natural gas is another major russian
export and a key ingredient in making
nitrogen-based fertilizer
fertilizer is about three to four times
costlier now than in 2020 and farmers
around the world are feeling the pinch
high fertilizer prices has affected
really the flow of of how our operation
does business and really it comes down
to timing and how much risk does the
retailer take how much risk does a
farmer take
grant wells is a third generation corn
and soybean farmer in fonda iowa he's
also the ceo and owner of wells ag
supply an agriculture retail business
when the russian war hit in in february
is really when things started going wild
is when things started doubling tripling
and so it's really going to affect what
the decision making and
what farmers profitability is going to
be in 2023 higher fertilizer prices
translate into higher production costs
for farmers who already operate on tight
profit margins
it's also leading to delays in farmers
planting schedules which could create
supply chain snags as crops are
harvested later in the season most
farmers i see delaying that
decision-making process to later in the
season you know instead of maybe
november december they're probably going
to sit on their hands and wait till jan
feb march hoping for some sort of a
price reduction and if that doesn't
happen then they'll choose to decide you
know how much can get cut back applying
less fertilizer could also lead to lower
crop yields while some u.s farmers plan
to cut back on their overall fertilizer
use others are shifting their acres
toward less fertilizer intensive crops
soybeans for instance don't require as
much nitrogen-based fertilizer so it's
usually a battle in iowa or in the
midwest between corn and soybeans and so
farmers will look at alternatives to
corn corn is a lot more dominating on
the fertility needs according to the u.s
department of agriculture the net income
for farmers reached around 119 billion
dollars in fiscal year 2021 the highest
in eight years but higher fertilizer
prices and other rising costs such as
herbicides are squeezing their profit
margins
that means grocery bills could go up
even more in 2022 following a year in
which global food prices rose to decade
highs
it appears that food costs are high and
farmers are benefiting but that is not
the case profit margins are the same
consumers are just unfortunately having
to pay more
to put food on their own table higher
corn and soybean prices for example
raise the cost of animal feed for meat
companies which pass along the increase
to consumers and i think the worst case
scenario is that
we don't have fertilizer at all to apply
to the crops and then that becomes a
feed and food production issue if we
don't produce the crops we can't
probably produce the livestock and the
poultry and we get into actual food
challenges in the u.s and that would be
a much much greater concern than what we
have today
meanwhile some u.s farmers are looking
at commercial fertilizer alternatives
biologicals for instance are natural
fertilizers containing microorganisms
that enhance soil fertility the high
prices are forcing us to look at
alternative ways to how we've applied
fertilizer to be more precise and to
look at alternatives like what a
biological can do but switching to
biologicals or trying new techniques may
carry risks for farmers who rely on
consistent crop yields to make a profit
if they try something different one year
and their yields are down crop doesn't
come in like they want
then like that's it for the year that is
their income they need it to work they
can't really take the risk
as fertilizer prices continue to rise
the agriculture industry braces for the
long-term impacts on food production you
know the solutions are very difficult to
this because it comes down to
uh oil production natural gas supplies i
think there's a very good chance that
fertilizer costs could continue to
increase and we could go into the 2023
crop year with even higher fertilizer
costs than what we've had in 2022
[Music]